As soon as we landed in London,
I started craving Indian food,
and since London is one of the best places to get it,
that's exactly what we did.
We went to Jim Connor, and they gave us a private room,
which I always appreciate at restaurants.
We started with drinks. I always love a fun drink.
I got a mango ginger ale,
while lucky got some pomegranate mocktail with black salt.
These were both so, so good.
And right after they came out,
our appetizers came out.
Lucky didn't quite know how to work the pani puri,
but these were probably one of my favorite things.
Burst the shell and then stuff it with spiced potatoes
and pour this green watery sauce on top and eat it.
Absolutely stunning. The rest of our starters started coming out,
which was some chicken tikka.
I think the other dish was aloo gobi.
Forgive me if I'm butchering all of these names,
but both of these things were absolutely insane.
Potatoes had some yogurt sauce on top with some tamarind,
and the chicken was perfectly spiced and juicy.
After finishing off all of our starters,
we moved on to our mains. We did go a little overboard,
but we just couldn't help but try a lot of different things.
We got some garlic naan, lentil Dal,
vindaloo, and some biryani.
All of it was so insanely good.
The meat was so tender. Vindaloo was with pork cheek,
and the biryani had deer Meat in it.
It was absolutely stunning.
Finished off our main course with this non
that was stuffed with some venison.
I topped it with some pomegranate yogurt to tone down the spice.
I started tapping out at this point,
but lucky continued finishing all of our mains
while I almost fell asleep.
Lucky was done. He got the check,
and then it was time for us to head back to our hotel.
Since I wanted something sweet the night before,
I had the most delicious vanilla ice cream at our hotel.
So I ordered three scoops of that today again
and headed straight to bed after.